some of you may be wondering if you're
ready for
this looking for something new to
watch in 2024 Prime
delivers if you insist on staying then
you will have to
adapt Hokie
dokie you've just been upgraded first
class find something you'll tell your
friends
[Music]
about this your first time in New York
have you ever killed
anyone yeah one
2 whatever it takes we'll be together
find big Journeys and even bigger
World BFFs to Ricky steni the best
friend we never
had
hey Heroes
villains and Sidekicks we don't use that
term what's your code name again the
boys who came up with
that I just slapped you are you all
[Music]
right
today it's
[Applause]
personal
JLo Snoop iamn Jason two J's Jennings he
looks like a black Princess Leia
Donald Nicole who do we think we are and
an what will people say I don't care
what they
say they just keep on coming huh yeah
they don't stop I'm not in this for the
romance
[Music]
good
what do you think happens now with our
marriage our
[Music]
mission find your happy place that's
amazing
that